j'ai toujours aimé l'idée que le devez
nous appartiennent ils ont changé comme
on le souhaite pierre regarder son
cheval jappeloup tu vas pas le vendre
j'en sais rien la puce c'est un tout
petit modèle et opter jamais levé pour
aller mon choix
c'est comme pour les filles faut que tu
fasses le choix
avoir une vie de petit bourgeois celle
là cavalier qui travaille dur pour être
un jour champion olympique à séoul
parce que c'était aux rêves c'est devenu
une bien je me suis toujours demandé ce
que ça pourrait être ses choix on était
à cheval n'a pas trop perdu
du coeur de cheval et même plus que ça
plus parler de médaille de dollars de
carrière chez lui vous pensé à lui vous
avez rien compris
vous avez raison c'est un bon fan je
suis pas mon cas veille si tu as arrêté
arrête tu aimerais mois n'aura jamais
aucun regret on a fait tout ça parce
qu'on t'aime tu n'as rien à prouver je
sais que tu m'aimes aussi tu te rends
compte la progression tu as eue avec ce
cheval la joie que ça procure à tout le
monde et surtout à ton père les états le
père de mon enfant un mec qui n'a pas pu
se battre que ça
il a besoin de votre confiance et vous
de la sienne
c'est pour ça qu'ils s'arrêtent
suis prêt à prendre à ma prochaine mais
je viens m'aider
s'arrête pas là bas ça sur les
territoires